let's go downstairs he is with Rob ja
tell us about the last basket what you
saw develop in front of you and getting
to the basket delay this late in the
game they started switching my ball
string the coach called my number he
told me to attack when I come off
waiter than just attack the rack and
didn't make a play and I got by the
defender and I seen like a clear Lane so
I just took second half defensively you
guys seemed to make changes and seemed
to really step up your game what changed
offensively for you my mom I said we
always preach to always go out and
compete and play together and have each
other back then tonight we all locked in
together a halftime and said we need to
stop and we went out in just Fault and
got stops and was able to score another
in through the first handful of games we
talked so much about learning
experiences to get to wins both on the
road what's that say about where this
team has grown so far early in the
season I feel out we still growing
I feel like I'm I said just change from
day one we just kept everybody have this
mindset to get better next game next
plate next shot mentality and we know we
have to lock in and coming on the road
is hard to win on the road my my college
coach always said good teams would have
all great teams went on the road and
this road trip we were just trying to do
it that we could come out win yeah a lot
of folks wearing your Jersey here
tonight how much fun to play in front of
some home fans
it felt good I'm just been able to come
out and show love and also to be able to
deliver the game-winning basket um with
all them here it just felt good I can't
say too much about it John
congratulations creaking thank you
John Morant it's the first of many
spectacular efforts and game-winning
shots 23 points 11 assists comes up huge
in the